y
[Música]
el presidente de kazajistán dio órdenes
de disparar a matar a los manifestantes
que llamo bandidos y terroristas tras
los disturbios originados por la subida
de los precios del combustible confirmó
que fuerzas enviadas desde rusia y los
estados vecinos llegaron para garantizar
la seguridad
américa latina' de extremas medidas por
la variante micro del coronavirus brasil
registra su primera muerte los casos
están disparados en argentina y colombia
perú tiene nuevas restricciones y chile
inicia con la cuarta dosis de la vacuna
y el gobierno francés cree que la
explosión de la semana pasada que hirió
a un piloto francés en el rally dakar
pudo ser un atentado terrorista durante
la tradicional carrera en arabia saudita
el ministerio de relaciones exteriores
hizo la advertencia
regresamos con ustedes para más noticias
en france 24 e iniciamos con kazajistán
el presidente de la república
centroasiática a casi 1000 omar de
cotoca y efe dijo que había dado órdenes
de disparar a matar frente a los
disturbios de esta semana por la subida
de los precios del combustible el
mandatario afirmó que hasta 20 mil
manifestantes que llamo bandidos y
terroristas atacaron al mati y agregó
que aquellos que no se rindieran serían
destruidos
asimismo rechazó pedidos para mantener
conversaciones con los manifestantes y
dijo que fuerzas de mantenimiento de la
paz enviadas desde rusia y los estados
vecinos habían llegado a solicitud de
kazajistán para garantizar la seguridad
estarán las revistas continúan dañando
la propiedad pública y privada
utilizando armas contra los ciudadanos
instruye a las fuerzas del orden y al
ejército a disparar sin previo aviso
hubo llamados del exterior para que las
partes negocien pacíficamente que
absurdo que negociación puede darse con
criminales con asesinos tenemos que
enfrentar a estos bandidos entrenados
locales y extranjeros bandidos y
terroristas por eso debemos destruirlos
y lo haremos pronto unionista wright
este jueves unas 3.000 personas fueron
detenidos en el país asiático como viene
ocurriendo desde comienzos de semana
estas protestas sacuden sobre todo la
ciudad de almaty la capital económica y
también se viven en nursultán a la
capital veamos el recuento de la jornada
de ayer
varios edificios oficiales en ruinas
autos calcinados e incluso calles
manchadas de sangre en la ciudad más
grande de kazajistán es el panorama de
la peor agitación política en el país
desde la caída de la unión soviética
hace 30 años
almaty fue el epicentro de nuevo de los
mayores enfrentamientos el miércoles y
el jueves con los manifestantes
asaltando instalaciones gubernamentales
una residencia presidencial y tomándose
el aeropuerto obligando a la cancelación
de vuelos a comienzos del viernes el
presidente casi me llamara tokáyev
afirmó que el orden había sido
restaurado confirmando que la policía
dio de baja a docenas de manifestantes
también dijo que murieron docenas de
miembros de las fuerzas de seguridad
pero las fuerzas kazajas también
pidieron ayuda desde el extranjero
después de que el presidente apeló a la
organización del tratado de seguridad
colectiva rusia y a otros miembros de la
alianza regional a que envíen tropas al
país una maniobra que eeuu afirmó estar
monitoreando de cerca
tenemos preguntas sobre la naturaleza de
esta petición y si es una legítima
invitación o no no sabemos en este punto
enright junto con el mundo estaremos
vigilando cualquier violación de los
derechos humanos mientras tanto el
presidente toca ayer declaró que el
gobierno restauraría el rubro de algunos
de los precios del gas licuado siendo el
aumento de esta materia prima el
detonante de las marchas
pero puede que sea ya muy tarde
estas manifestaciones han evolucionado
en un descontento mayor contra el
autoritarismo y la corrupción asuntos
que el gobierno no ha abordado con éxito
noticias de hong kong a más de 100
personas incluidos varios políticos
entraron a cuarentena después de una
fiesta de cumpleaños del delegado de la
ciudad ante el parlamento chino hasta 19
diputados de la asamblea legislativa el
parlamento hongkonés asistieron al
evento en el que estuvieron en contacto
con al menos dos casos sospechosos de
kobe la reunión se hizo a pesar del
pedido de beijing de evitar encuentros
por los brotes de la variante o micro
en otros temas de hoy me se registró un
nuevo récord de casos globales de kobe
de en un día 26 millones y en américa
latina' de este jueves a la nueva
variante provocó la primera muerte en
brasil causó un número récord de casos
en argentina obligó a chile a ofrecer
una cuerda dosis de la vacuna y fuerzo a
perú a anunciar nuevas restricciones
luís muñoz hace un recorrido de la
situación
chile será el primer país de américa
latina en inocular la cuarta dosis
cuenta con más del 85% de la población
con dos inyecciones mientras que el 57%
ya tiene tres inoculaciones desde el 10
de enero los inmunodeprimidos podrán
acceder a la cuarta dosis así lo anunció
el presidente sebastián piñera
experiencia nos ha mostrado que la
eficacia de las vacunas y también de los
refuerzos
disminuye con el tiempo y también con la
aparición de nuevas variantes
como omicron que ya afecta con fuerza
todo el continente especialmente a
argentina donde este jueves se registró
récord de contagios con más de 100.000
en 24 horas una tendencia que también
sigue colombia donde se registraron más
de 23.000 casos un día después de que el
gobierno advirtiese de que se podría
llegar a los 40 mil casos diarios aunque
los expertos avisan de que se está
produciendo un subregistro
y aunque según estudios omicron podría
ser menos letal brasilia cuenta con su
primera muerte por la variante un hombre
de 68 años con tres dosis y morbilidad
es falleció en aparecida de goiánia en
goiás cuando la variante ya es
responsable del 93 5% de los casos
en perú país con mayor tasa de huérfanos
por kobe del mundo el gobierno de pedro
castillo reimpulso toques de queda en
lima y en otras 24 provincias del país
entre las 11 de la noche y las 4 de la
mañana un incremento de casos muy rápido
y sustancial en particular en liba pero
también a nivel nacional lo cual
confirma el inicio de una tercera ola
unos apuestan por restricciones y cubas
sigue apostando por la vacunación masiva
espera administrar la tercera dosis a
toda su población en enero mientras este
jueves ha enviado un millón de vacunas
soberana 2 para niños a nicaragua en
haití fallecieron dos periodistas
durante un tiroteo a las afueras de
puerto príncipe cuando realizaban un
reportaje sobre la inseguridad en la
zona controlada pandillas los reporteros
eran de radio de qt de canadá en medio
en línea canadiense un tercero logró
escapar con ayuda de habitantes de la
zona la violencia es cada vez mayor en
la nación más pobre de las américas la
semana pasada el primer ministro ariel
henry sobrevivió a un intento de
asesinato mientras se conmemoraba el día
de la independencia
en otras noticias la presidenta de la
comisión europea- úrsula a vanderlei en
está de visita oficial en parís el
presidente francés emmanuel macro no le
dio la bienvenida en el palacio del
elíseo marcando el inicio de la
presidencia francesa de la unión europea
durante seis meses los líderes
discutieron los retos de la vacunación
las tensiones con ucrania y pidieron el
fin de la violencia en kazajistán
el gobierno francés considera que la
explosión que hirió la semana pasada a
un piloto francés en el marco del rally
dakar en arabia saudita podría haber
sido un atentado terrorista son palabras
del ministro de exteriores el jean yves
le drian que abrió la puerta a que se
cancele esta tradicional carrera que ya
en el pasado se ha visto afectada por
amenazas cuando recorría el continente
africano ya ha habido atentados
terroristas en arabia saudita contra los
intereses franceses era importante
proteger a nuestros conciudadanos la
pérdida prevenir y solicitar la mayor
transparencia por lo tanto la fiscalía
nacional antiterrorista ha tomado el
caso puede que haya habido un atentado
terrorista contra el dakar twitteros el
barril puede ser que por eso valga la
pena renunciar a este evento deportivo y
los organizadores han decidido continuar
pero la prudencia en este caso nos hace
tener mucha precaución la de esta
ecuación se conmemora en francia el
séptimo aniversario de los ataques
contra la revista de charlie hebdo y
contra un supermercado coches atentados
que acabaron con la vida de 17 personas
en 2015 las oficinas de charly fueron
asaltadas por los hermanos saíz y
sheriff washing que dispararon y mataron
a 12 personas el ataque le siguió un día
después el asesinato de una policía por
ahmed y coulibaly seguido por el estado
islámico que también atacó una tienda
judía en las afueras de parís donde
asesinó a cuatro rehenes en diciembre de
2020 un tribunal les condenó a 14
personas por los hechos
y los cristianos ortodoxos celebran la
navidad este 7 de enero en oriente medio
rusia y otras iglesias ortodoxas que
utilizan el antiguo calendario juliano
en lugar del calendario gregoriano del
siglo 17 adoptado por los católicos
protestantes ortodoxos griegos y de uso
común en el mundo el patriarca ruso
kiril él celebró un servicio de
nochebuena en la catedral de cristo
salvador en moscú
recuerde que tenemos más noticias en
france 24 punto com siga con nosotros ya
volvemos
[Música]